um you and mazzy putting out the joint
album
it's a big [ __ ] deal for the west
coast last year um
you have obviously been locked in with
maji for a very long time really before
he was kind of on this run that he's
been on where he was kind of like a
household name
um
but what was like uh was it was it a a
purposeful thing you guys went in and
did it or were you guys just working
because i know you were in with dave and
like like you guys were working just a
lot did it just feel like you know what
we got all these records cut let's just
do a [ __ ] album like what how did
that wow
like we had started working just on some
[ __ ] before we just started working and
we did some records
and then um
like like it was like top of 20 21 i
think you know what i'm saying
they got pulled up on me like bros like
yeah i'm saying
like what you thinking about doing a
project and bro it's the middle of
covert ain't nobody really got that
going on we just like trying to kill tom
and then i'm like
hmm
mazzy that's my that's my fella fella
fella
you know what i'm saying i'm like bro
and then you feminist right before us
like
sauced uh me and mozzie we locked in
and started working right before i was
finished start working on my album
so i'm like bro this is the perfect time
to get in with broca's bro be rapping
like he be saying he'll be talking that
[ __ ]
so like and i'm like a part like
you feel me if you put me on a court
with a [ __ ] nba player bro i'm a hoop
like i'm playing like playing the nba
you feel me
that's what i think
but um
so i locked in with miley so
i'm like yeah this shouldn't be good
it's gonna be some good you know what
i'm saying
like get my [ __ ] right for my [ __ ] and
do some dope [ __ ] for the culture that's
been needed anyway
you know i'm saying with somebody i i
really [ __ ] with
so uh what they will have to um come
just like you should be the homie you
shouldn't be here rod he was out here
bro we need to do that we need to do
that right there yeah yeah yeah i'm like
yeah
yeah let's go
so you feel me we did it we uh we called
guys to be like yeah guys come on we
gonna do this through empire don't even
worry about nothing
you feel me guys he was like let's go
and we had fun we was recording having
fun you guys were like in cabo right
doing a lot of [ __ ] yeah we ended up
going to cabo to shoot the video in for
my birthday mm-hmm but we went to go
shoot like two like two videos out there
and that [ __ ] was evolved everybody came
out there blast mazzy we had young young
man out there it was a gang of homies it
was like
it was like it was like [ __ ] galore out
there [ __ ] galore
uh
lady galore women's lore pretty [ __ ]
galore yeah fatty galore stripper galore
a lot of imports from options a lot of
options